[Aplausos]
antes mais um dia todos e todas
quero agradecer o convite da organização
e trabalho que têm feito é ter memória
que tenho 25 anos 80 é tentar explicar o
conformismo podem não dar as nossas
vidas com várias situações várias vezes
para ele o barulho da máquina o final e
ouvia que eu não fazia a mesma coisa com
o meu irmão ea minha não vai ter com a
lei se a situação não acontecer eu
passava muitas vezes escolhe um pouco de
volta em casa
muita gente porque essa diferença de
tratamento dos meus pais
[Música]
a história de fotos é tanto nova e não
11 como achamos que me interessa muito
errada e outro que comemora a gente que
não queriam falar comigo nunca tratei
desse assunto comigo porque eu é mulher
e provavelmente não seria ficar acontece
que eu descia carros mas isso não é
motivo suficiente para me fazer falar
comigo e é uma situação que vinha em
conta com qual é a minha trabalho e
única eu de teorias ilustrar com as
coisas que eu não disse se eu pensar e
eu tenho uma filha e ou então violenta
eu espero que tanto filho num dos
confrontos com ninguém que tenha essa
mesma atitude do deputado ter comigo
porque é chato é triste não há
justificação para que isso aconteça o
que é o filme é o filme rodado desligar
de oportunidades entre homens em média
metade não é a o oposto do machismo nela
aberto é esse movimento é porque ele
perde tudo igualado por todos e todas já
em qualquer aspecto indicação solares
trabalho e por aí fora
o feminismo a igualdade entre homens e
mulheres é o tenho tentado muito na moda
mas não não é uma moda que o filho dele
está sempre na moda e com a própria
imagem disso a ser sempre fish também
geram conceito muito mais abrangente
porque implica que o mesmo só como uma
questão de direitos dos médicos
ele só não vê isso com um certo mas é
legal e entrar então os homens dentro
desta questão é por quanto mais formos
armado no mesmo sentido mais com essas
vemos a
[Música]
idealmente seria bom estarmos nos será
muito mais é justa e igualitária coisa
competitiva é por quem os homens e
mulheres né mesmo
será melhor também finalmente a
sociedade muito mais competitiva é e
produto é inclusiva mesmo e não se
entendam quanto a vitória porque os
rapazes acreditam que não é presos que
não fazem falta e que não sintam o que
vocês fazem falta vocês não precisam é é
muito mais fácil é trabalhar nesse
sentido
surgiu então 2010 2014
a anp está na agência e tem com cada
onça em muito mais inclusive em tempo
integral da sua agenda a realização do
homens e rapazes na nesse quarto e e
fizemos ver mesmo que eu sou os alunos
precisam ser posta de parte e que tem
efetivamente ao dizer que uma sociedade
sem bola acaba por prejudicar também a
vida dos homens uma imagem dum grupo
trabalhos que nós sabemos que no final
de 2016 oficialmente só em março de 2017
a rua na entrada e estão em obra e nós
temos a trabalhar sobre sexo na áfrica
silêncio absoluto violência entra lá
política educação e com 3 a 2 portanto
não se observa os três em conjunto
pode servir apenas um dia ou jogo dois
sentidos
tudo isso é tanto os dados as empresas e
os governos em portugal educação é um
problema sério de construir sites do
exterior já tentaram explicar a mão mais
uma vez não é apenas uma questão de
ética
estamos a falar de efetivamente direitos
humanos todos os anos 2000 e 2006
aqui tem agora um grande protesto não só
a nível nacional como internacional
assim os jovens jogadores
a decisão só é importante em todos os
componentes também está em alta de 0 20
mais de 10 a 15 de janeiro
mas é em alguns exemplos nunca se voltar
ao trabalho
é importante você está estourando o teto
salarial também funciona com um lado
mais de 700 a mil por hora num negócio
segmento cerca de 75 por cento do que um
isso é muito feio da união do país
porque a finalidade de aulas num aumento
de 23%
[Música]
ainda assim os entraves à produção da
ilha é um táxi são e onde estão muitas
vezes associadas do sol que normalmente
está numa altura em que o feto em quando
o caminho que pode ser um entrave ao
desenvolvimento quer porque nós fizemos
foi aumentar aquilo que quer fazer da
sua vida está em portugal é obrigatório
de 25 16 em apenas 35 mil novecentos e
vinte linhas fixas não precisarão pensei
que iria porém fez técnica que estava
num momento de de produção e os jovens
também podem ser aproveitados por terem
efe o filho e acho que isso era mais
tempo escrita a entrar no q3 exemplos de
photoshop ou do minério no pré-sal em
cópias de teste deve ser muito forte de
forma pacífica através do diálogo é ea
três coisas que sinto em que vocês podem
fazer a todos os dias
a primeira transmissão você tem que
olhar é por umas lentes de um ano e que
será essa situação com que são
confrontados está correta ou não
muitas agências depois fazer o nosso
ficado ontem que tim segue estas duas
vezes 2
as duas ações o denunciado não ser
cúmplice de situações de desigualdade de
ano são fulcrais para que no futuro é e
hoje nós ficamos sabendo 45 pessoas que
já têm em atenção a essas questões
já os sensores muito mais contínuos de
que os passos finais em concepções que
vão usar o peguete ninhos fica
exatamente pela turnê é é e quer fazer
do mundo um momento muito melhor amiga
ea costuma dizer que os direitos humanos
chão como músico ano e com todos os
músicos precisam ser licitadas
portanto esse sempre existem os nossos
direitos mas que eles precisem e não
significa que a ajuda não é e achei e
obrigado pela vossa presença
[Aplausos]